look being successful is hard but to
stay successful is super super hard
matter of fact just recently I finished
the book by Jim Collins not good to
create a different one with that I want
to share with everybody I think
everybody in today's economy has to read
this book he doesn't talk about the keys
to success he talks about the five
stages that entrepreneurs business
owners CEOs go through that eventually
causes them to go out of business and
we're going to talk about that today
[Music]
thank you
we're about to go out of business I'm
panicking this is how much money I got
on savings my employees are complaining
about this I'm going through that
whether it's real estate more it doesn't
matter many different industries that
they're calling me but the book explains
five stages let me share with you what
prompted us want to make this video so
many business people today that we're
consulting or calling us talking about
Pat I think we're done I don't think we
can do anything else right now to save
our business and I'm telling you right
now 90 of people who say that you're not
done yet
stage number five for some of you that
are there you are done but ninety
percent of you are not down he'll
explain to you what the stage number
five is for the right person watching
this you're going to call this the best
video you watch with valentineman for
years so let's get right into it by the
way I challenge you to watch this with
an open mind because some of the stuff I
say it's going to be directed to you
it's going to sting it's going to be
hard and probably nobody is telling you
any of this stuff but I'm going to be
telling you this stuff if you are in
this situation and hopefully you'll do
about it because the same way a person
doesn't become successful overnight is
the same way the person doesn't go out
of business overnight there's certain
things and behaviors you and I do that
causes this business to get to that
level so out of the five stages okay
once you reach stage number five you're
going out of business that's when it's
death and the capitulation of your
business we'll get to that here in a
minute but most of the time you can save
your business so let's go through it the
author Jim Collins writes a book called
How to Mighty Fall in had a Mighty Fall
he explains these five different stages
that businesses go through stage number
one he calls it the hubris
born of success so what does this mean
look this is a phase where you're
winning you're doing great everybody's
telling you're amazing you're living in
a nice place driving the nice cars have
money in the bank eating at the right
places you start saying things like we
didn't get lucky it was 100 me we're the
best no one's better than us and all of
a sudden you become entitled to success
like an almost entitlement feeling of
success is always going to be here we're
never going to lose it because we're
smarter than everybody else that phase
when you go through that phase bad
things are about to happen next so this
stage is when you start kind of feeling
like let me tell you we won because
we're smarter than everybody we're
better than everybody we're stronger
than everybody we become overly
confident and it's seen and so you
become entitled to success we're going
to deserve the next level of success we
didn't get lucky it was all us it's 100
hard work it's because of this and you
get a casual a little bit you show up a
little bit later you are no longer that
intentional your level of paranoia drops
you put your are down and that
unfortunately leads to the next stage
stage number two undisciplined pursuit
of more and what is pursuit of mourning
what's wrong with being pursuit of
Market aren't we supposed to be
ambitious about going more yes but the
mindset becomes hey more Innovation more
Innovation more Innovation that's what
we got to do rather than hey let's take
what we got here let's go deep with it
the other day I had a meeting uh four
weeks ago with our guys and I went
upstairs and I said listen guys we keep
trying to add more companies and more
products and More Everything here's all
I want to do these are the products that
we have these are the companies that
we're running I don't want anything else
how can we take these things deeper and
what can we get rid of okay Rubbermaid a
company a case study that the author
talks about in the book is they had a
few different products that were killing
it all of a sudden they went from having
a few different products they went so
wide that they couldn't go deeper to
scale they said we're going to produce
one new product every day three years
later and have a thousand products how
do you manage a thousand products how do
you drive a thousand different products
Steve Jobs after he got fired the second
time around that he came back he looked
at all these different products Apple
had they're about to go out of business
nope focused
high-end computer that's going to be
more you know that can do more than low
than cost four this is what we're doing
this is what we're selling these are our
customers let's stay focused on this and
then Apple came back up and then it
introduced the iPad the all the other
stuff so as much as Innovation is good
over innovation of going too light ends
up leading to lack of focus stage number
three denial of risk and Peril and by
the way this one's a little bit
interesting because this is when you
know how typically you're doing a
leadership meeting and you talk about
data well let me tell you what we did
last month well let me tell you what we
did last month and let me tell you what
we did last month let me tell you what
we did last quarter let me tell you what
we did last year leaders don't want to
touch data anymore and everything
becomes guys we have to stay positive we
can't look at the negative stuff the
authors explain let me read you exactly
how he reads it he says the leaders of
the company upsell the positives and
ignore the negatives does this sound
familiar to you within your business if
it does you may be at stage three you're
concerned about what's going on and your
key guys are sitting there saying that
does our leader have the audacity to
talk about what things we need to
improve because I need some real data
the company at this space stops paying
attention to the negative data on what
solutions to come in they just kind of
look this way avoiding all the issues
that have here on this side stage number
four graspin for salvation at this phase
let me tell you what's going on so this
kind of makes sense to you at this stage
everyone knows the client is here
employees customers maybe even the
market you can no longer hide it by just
talking about the positives people know
something is going on no matter how much
you try to hide it you can't do it so
now you as the leader are exposed so you
sit there like oh my God what do we do
hey let's hire McKenzie
they can solve our problems let's bring
them in let's hire the next consulting
company let's bring those guys in let's
do something for sale let's do the next
creative campaign let's just try this
and let's just try that and let's just
do this and let's just do that in your
panicking and everybody's like panicking
family panic and anxiety anxiety anxiety
anxiety anxiety and you're like oh my
rather than wanting to go back to the
basic fundamentals which when I tell you
the story of what this female CEO of
Xerox did you're gonna sit there and say
this makes a lot of sense but everybody
wants to get too you know trying to
figure out a quick fix and the last
thing you're looking at is what got us
to this point we're spending way too
much time thinking about what we do we
forgot why the hell were we doing what
we were doing the why becomes the last
thing on your mind all you're starting
to think about is a quick fix and
unfortunately if you stay in that stage
for too long you go to station number
five and stage number five is
capitulation to irrelevance or death and
what does this mean you're about to go
out of business and why here's what
happens hope the whole word of hope hope
of future having faith things are going
to work itself out that's completely
gone people are afraid they get tight
with money money start to go employees
are getting afraid employees are
starting to quit and one day you're
sitting there saying oh my God what do
we do now and it's too late you're out
of business
if you're watching this and this just
kind of give you a heavy heavy feeling
right here I understand I've been there
too it sucks it's not a lot of fun but
I'm telling you there's a high chance
you're not at stage number five yet
you're probably at three or four but
thank God you're watching this video to
get this content for yourself so in this
situation what do you do well
let me tell you the story of Xerox okay
with this lady named Anne mokahy and
mukhahi got started with Xerox in 1976
she started working there okay 24 years
later she was in sales for 16 years she
was just a field rep as what she was 24
years later August of 2001 the board
comes up to her and says hey I'm okay
yes we kind of want to make you to CEO
and she's like oh my God you're making
me the co do you realize when you're
making me the CEO yeah we kind of want
you to be the CEO no problem I'll take
it great attitude simple woman high
energy came from sales she understood
the hard work that sales people put in
she respected salespeople she was
awesome and the field shaking hands hey
how you guys doing you guys good you
guys talking to customers when she took
over as a CEO you ready the company had
only 100 million dollars in cash this is
a one now keep in mind some people may
say Pat 100 million dollars that's a lot
of money in cash
yes you have 100 million dollars in cash
but you got 19 billion dollars of debt
let me say that one more time
19 billion dollars of debt you have 100
million dollars of cash just to put that
in perspective that means you got 190
000 of credit card debt but you only
have a thousand dollars in the bank how
would you feel and they said here you go
you're officially the CEO of Xerox and
she comes in what the hell do we do the
year she became the CEO Xerox lost
376 million dollars in 01. so she sat
there rather than getting super super
creative she went back remembered what
she did in sales she went back telling
the story selling the dream selling the
vision going back to the basic
fundamentals talking to everybody with
this Mission getting excited about what
worked we don't need 50 new products we
don't need 100 new products we don't
need to go higher
all these consultants and spent our
money thinking about that these are the
guys are going to save us the money
she went in and she went back to basic
fundamentals and people started feeling
her hope her excitement her enthusiasm a
couple years later that net profits of a
billion dollars a couple years later she
was recognized as the CEO of the year my
chief executive magazine she was number
six on woman of the year on Forbes
Magazine she was on so many differently
she talked at Harvard she next thing you
know she's sitting on the board of City
everybody wanted to work with this lady
because they brought someone who
understood the basic fundamentals she
was excited she was enthusiastic she
unified she brought people together
saying yes we have these mistakes yes
these are real numbers yes we're 19
billion dollars in debt yes we only have
100 million dollars in cash but we can
do something about it and that energy
became infectious so now if you're
watching the same old path how do we
find people like this the book explains
the five qualities you look for specific
people that help you take the company
the next level I'm going to share with
you what those five qualities are
alright so the five qualities Jim
Collins talks about are the following
number one look for people who fit with
company values a lot of times you may
find a very talented person but they
don't fit the company values it's not
going to work out by the way while
you're in this situation we're like What
do we do next with the company these are
also the five qualities you're looking
for to help take the company to the next
level but he's talking about that you
also look at this while you're hiring
everybody so again number one look for
people that fit the company values
number two right people don't need to be
tightly managed if you're overly
managing somebody constantly to see what
they're doing they're not the right
people the right people they just say
here's the job here's what we're doing
they're going to go get the job done
they don't have to constantly be tightly
managed number three they don't look at
the job as a job they look at it as
purely a responsibility they take it
personally to say hey man that's my job
it's on me I'm going to get this fixed
don't worry about it I got it there's a
certain feeling where it's like oh it's
not my job I didn't do this it sat on me
which I don't have to do anything this
it's purely responsibility they're like
oh I can't believe we're working this
those types of things don't come out of
their mouth all they think about is it's
my responsibility we're going to get it
done number four they fulfill their
commitment they keep to you and they're
very careful to never over commit so a
lot of times you may have certain people
that are going to tell you I think we're
going to do this and they constantly
fall short I think we're going to do
this and they constantly fall short I
look at it as a test we take in school
what's an a 90 or higher B is 80 or
higher C is 70 or higher D is 60 or
higher anything at all sixty percent is
what failed if a person tells me Pat I
think we're going to do three million
dollars this month they do 2.7 million
that's 90 of what they said they're
going to do that's still an a of course
you want them to do what 3.1 million but
that's still in the eight category
somebody says we're going to do three
million dollars this month and they do
1.2 million that's fail and if they
continuously tell you what they're going
to be doing and they keep failing that's
not somebody they can rely on long term
you want people that give you a number
that's not easy it's a stretch but they
do whatever they can within their power
energy to keep their word to come
through for the company number five
passionate about their work and not just
passionate about their work like oh this
person loves what they're doing with
their jobs not that they don't need all
the shine they don't need all the credit
they constantly want to give the shine
to other people let me tell you what
this person did let me tell you what
Johnny did hey I got to tell you hey hey
Jack great job with your project on what
you guys did no Pat it was great but let
me tell you Larry was here with us till
midnight Johnny was here till with us to
midnight do you know what Jackie did the
other day she went out there into the
city to get the permits
so they're willing to constantly give
that shine and when it comes down to
pressure type situations like this and
and Mulcahy who is just a field rep for
16 years when she got started at 1976 24
years later gets nominated by the board
to become the CEO and she becomes the
CEO of the Year by Chief Executive
magazine and she's on Forbes as one of
the most powerful women in the world how
does this happen she just started as a
sales rep
she had these five qualities and these
five qualities eventually leaders like
this with these five qualities are
trusted by board or others who say I
think you're ready to take this company
to the next level so there you have it
now you know what you need to do to not
fall under the fifth state so the future
looks bright for someone like you two
things I want to share with you number
one these latest hats just came we just
had a merch drop what I love about these
new hats that we did this is purely
custom handmade future looks bright
statement on the side future looks
bright here and the vitamin logos on the
inside everything I want when I was
building my business I had laminations
on my shower wall I had quotes
everywhere in my wallet on my phone the
statement future looks bright I've
probably set a few hundred thousand
times I want it everywhere around me if
you haven't yet ordered your own limited
edition future looks bright you can
order one of the three or all the colors
black white or red click here to order
the hats they will sell out in no time
or second thing I want you to do is
watch the video how how to find your
running mate what qualities to look for
to find running made specifically with
these five things that Jim is talking
about if you've never watched that video
click you to watch it take care
everybody
[Music]